were you performing as a kid oh i loved
it so much my brother
bought me a video camera when i was
about nine years old and i became like a
tyrant making my own home movies and
getting my friends to like
do the spice girls there we are doing
two become one
irish posh spice and there's my best
friend maeva's baby spice
and yeah i was totally like a dictator
when it came to directing
we used to recreate episodes of friends
and
all this kind of other stuff but we just
yeah i loved it so much
oh man i love that too i was i was the
same kind of kid we were always doing
stuff like that
that was so embarrassing that i would
never want to show anyone whose dog was
that which dog was that was that paisley
that's paisley she's um she's
hey it's covered what do you want yeah
she's
having a moment sorry no i love it i'm
done because for a second i
was like do i have a dog but maybe
yeah it's like a wolf she's like she
needs the attention
sorry she's yeah no it's what i i
pointed it out because that's like i
think it's funny i literally had to
shoot my house the show
at some point and my dog henry i was
like he would just roam through the
scene i was like well okay
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever